I'm really happy that we managed to
reach consensus and to conclude to agree
to conclusions for General Affairs
Council for enlargement Yamada create
China basileus no let's push the desert
just discuss Esprit ksenia OSP Ahmed as
a member shaney
escrow - tonal dobro ZTR Appa necessary
Geon Austin etudes upon a balcony Nessa
ma vishweshwara Republica McCadden is
albania tortilla paprika texts achieve
of momenta nama me astronaut Fernanda
Nadia V vaginal rush any editor
co-produce Java the body challenge line
every PI skills to use of course you are
waiting for me to say something about
the hearing we had just had on Poland it
is the next step in the article 71
procedure need to solve this issue in a
European way through dialogue it is
essential for our common future that
Poland plays its historic role in the
European construction for that to happen
I honestly believe we have to make sure
that there is no longer a systemic
threat to the rule of law in Poland
today we have not seen any steps further
of the porous government they gave us a
state of played it did not indicate that
they would make further changes apart
from the changes they've already made
but I remain at their disposal to find
ways forward and the Commission will
continue to work for that